well there's something funny related to
the mainstream media here's CNN
misgendering Dylan Mulvaney
we even talked to a bar in Chicago one
bar who was telling us basically they're
not going to serve it because they don't
like the way Delvin Mulvaney was treated
after this whole controversy started he
courses the transgender uh person they
were gonna uh uh sponsor and go along
with with Bud Light they didn't like how
Bud Light didn't stand by him after all
this
it Ryan it's it's really interesting and
great that you got the temperature
um from people you were talking to it's
one of the it's the culture it's
something it's the culture wars it's a
tough time it is time Ray and young it
was a great story thank you okay so
there's a couple things first off the
guy calls Dylan Mulvaney him and he
repeatedly throughout that right that's
that's one thing that's funny about that
did you catch though that the story is
about how a bar is not serving Bud Light
because they're pissed about Dylan
Mulvaney being sponsored by Bud Light
the bar is no longer serving Bud Light
because they're pissed that Bud Light
didn't back Dylan Mulvaney after all of
this so Bud Light is just getting hit by
everybody which is exactly what they
deserve but because this fella
misgendered Dylan Mulvaney him he
repeatedly yes the next day CNN had to
issue an apology
we do want to make an important note
yesterday in a segment about transgender
influencer Dylan Mulvaney who was
featured in Bud light's recent campaign
she was mistakenly referred to by the
wrong pronoun and CNN aims to honor
individuals ways of identifying
themselves and we apologize for that
well she's a guy so
CNN thank you Carter uh CNN wants to
honor people's pronouns Unfortunately
they can honor journalism that would be
preferred if you asked me but you know
I'm old school
[Music]
thank you